hey gregory is it true you have a saucy
secret i i actually don't know what
you're talking about do you like to do
your house chores in the nude
in episode two greg he's got a bunch of
lines in his head about this is how i
stay neutral i'm just an observer i'm
not a part of this necessarily and it's
also a way of you hedging your bets what
about the papers i don't i maybe don't
even know what they are or where they
came from there's a nice agreement
without it being like a obvious
agreement it's like we're both gonna
shut the hell up here right okay well
we'll have to see if he buys that the
whole relationship is about like what
can i trade you what can you trade me
did you know that shiv's over there were
the kennels
what it's your game why what's
yours the episode itself came out of
that question of why don't they go for
logan when it feels so possible what are
their choices uh it's pretty simple
let's gang up on dad and take him down
jesus let me shut the door first it's
quite a alluring but quite a terrifying
power for kids to have over their father
and as i thought about each character
they've all just got really good reasons
to go for him and they've all got
reasons not to jesse writes in gray
areas so in a sense we're all on our own
in this family and then in another sense
we're deeply connected and enmeshed
just uh hear him out and report i think
roman is fully in dad's court because if
we banded together and got rid of dad
there's an uncertainty as to who's sort
of in charge and i will not work for my
siblings i could oversee us as ceo on
paper as we shift to these spheres of
influence and evaluate what is core as
we move forward so you'll oversee us but
it's all very complicated because i feel
for my brother there's still something
there look guys he was going to send me
to jail but also she has got some sort
of agenda
she's kind of positioning long enough
until you know what the greater mass is
doing if she's going to like push him
off course i should be there too because
then we did it or if she's jumping ship
then i can report that and that's a win
or i can jump ship two and it's win it's
all sorts of win when when do you win
win-win i think there's lots of ways for
him to win dad sent donuts
what the
i always like the feeling of language
being so important in our arguments but
then there being bigger forces at work
something as innocuous as donuts it
means so much it means your children he
wants us all to have a nice tea party he
may not have even known about the donors
he's going to know of course he is i
think it's to do with making sure
they're fed
i think it's a caring gesture they're in
a little bit of a garden of eden and
it's a bit like the don't answer god's
saying i see you there and you're all
naked and you're all disgusting and just
being seen is enough to change how you
feel very dramatically how diabolical is
that
khan stop looking at the donuts
man the old man is indestructible and
kendall is just fragile it's also
volatile is it the goddamn donuts have
you been spooked by donuts
that's pathetic shiv but behind all
anger is fear you're a prick oh
thanks for coming in person good night i
had expectations of things going a
certain way for me what but we're a
family that has a lot of conflict and
tension and
if that has been part of your identity
structure i think there's a need for
that opponent i think i need to get back
to the city
people need to see a little family unity
you